rest in peace breaker you're in
quedarnos house that's what I like about
enforcer is he's great up close he's
great vertical he's great at getting in
and out of combat that sort of whatever
pace the player feels like and he just
kind of can run the battlefield that way
so what I like about the enforcer is its
versatility if I'm using the Badger
close range the aerator long range or if
i'm using the EMP to shut down enemies I
always have something in my kit yeah my
favorite thing tends to be the
Bloodhound rockets I try to line it up
to where I can get a lot of distance
online and sometimes you can kind of
thread a needle through the environment
and some guy will do yards away from you
you know half the map away and you can
tag him with those things and send him
flying off the map a move i like to do
with the enforcer is get close with the
Badger and a tunnel or a tight space and
shoot them twice and then kick them away
and it usually takes care of anyone as a
support role is great by the enforcers
he has EMP grenade and you can throw it
into a group of enemies and lock them
down so that they can't use their
abilities and that allows enforces
teammates to kind of rain terror on them
which is pretty devastating so a cool
way to help out your allies is to use
your shift ability which is time
dilation you get into zero-g with that
both of you can get across the map
really quickly yourself can use it with
a line fire and gain even more speed
I like to split my targets so I'll use
my my rockets on one target and then
while that's happening I'll shift to an
adjacent target to be really
disorienting as the enemy so a tip for
using the enforcer is use the
time-dilation to kite enemies away from
you if you were to run up against an
assassin or a Titan you want a time
dilate and run backwards and shoot with
the aerator and you'll keep the distance
as well as Peppa them a shots you should
play enforcer if you like controlling
the pace of the game if you like to be a
running gunner he can help out in your
team you can do a lot of damage you have
a lot of abilities available to you that
help in multiple scenarios
you